this is a production of Cornell
University
so uh I love origin stories you know
like superheroes all that so like I got
my origin in my love of diversity and
plants from looking at teeth and you
look at shapes and sizes and colors of
teeth and really like all of that love I
think really like most of us might be
have fallen in love with biology because
of diversity whether that's on like the
molecular level just trying to figure
out why things work a certain way but
like agricultural diversity is so
exciting to work in because there's this
immediate connection with the public
because we've all eaten corn we've all
had carrots and then when you show
people like what's behind the scenes in
a grocery store like you very even this
is great of a store as wagons like
there's very little representation of
the full diversity in agriculture and
it's such a remarkable thing so these
are you know some of the seed crops that
are just so fantastic and colorful to
look at and these are our crops and so
you know I'm gonna talk to you today
about the the National collection of
apples tart cherries and grapes and
really it's important to note it like as
you get to know plant germplasm
collections plant genetic resource
collections like this is not like an
all-star show like this is not the
greatest hits of Apple this is really
like trying to maximize or really
preserve the full genetic diversity that
means like the extreme great apples are
mixed in with the terrible ones things
you'll never want to really taste or try
ever again so so we range in you know
from a sweet crunchy apple like Honey
Crisp down to like a styrofoam juiceless
apple and really all of that has
tremendous value in terms of you know
the future right so like my talk today
is is on preserving the future and
really like in collections we've a lot
of people come really excited and
interested in seeing old heirloom apples
there's a huge movement in there seeing
no heirloom grapes from the Geneva
collection really it's about preserving
the past present and all this effort
goes into like creating the future it's
like what our crops look like today will
depend on the genetic resources that
we're preserving
so as part of the national plan
germplasm system we have a mission to
acquire preserve characterized and
distribute genetic material of plants
and really it's a nation might be have
about you know five hundred ninety six
thousand accessions representative of
all of our major crops and most
importantly like their wild relatives
so not just crops but also their wild
relatives that can be useful for for
breeding and I love this quote by
Francois Jacob diversity is a way of
coping with the possible it acts as a
kind of insurance for the future so as
we think about sustainability in
agriculture like genetic diversity plays
a large role in that so here we are in
Geneva and so we have a USDA site there
partnered with Cornell Agrotech and it's
such a beautiful partnership not only do
we get a large portion of our starting
material for grapes from the great
breeding program an apple from Cornell's
apple breeding program but we have
partnership with entomologist
pathologists are there and it's such a a
strong you know team there that we have
to preserve our resources to make them
you know available worldwide
so other notable sites for our other
partner cops are Davis California which
is where we see the other part of the
grape collection and also the rest of
the prunus and Fort Collins comes into
play for us a lot that's our
cryopreservation backup site that I'll
I'll mention later
there's about 20 sites in total you know
really to maximize this this effort to
conserve diversity so there's a lot of
like analogies to gene banks and
especially we hear so many good ones
this is one of my favorite ones oh well
here oh you're like a Noah's Ark you're
like Noah's aren't your library of
apples this is one of my favorites does
anyone recognize this building yeah
world famous one of the best museums in
the world so what does the Louvre and
our collection have in common
and you can tell yeah
so this is your gonna get used to my
cheesy jokes when I do tours it's full
of cheesy jokes but like they're both
better to visit so if you I can sit here
and talk about our collections or you
can come visit the collection and taste
fruit you can walk through and like
really see how impressive so I I do so
many tours each year and there this is
actually kind of a painful experience
because I can't just like show you the
plants I can't reach over and show you
grape leaves and show you like how
they're different from one another and
so really like come and see the
diversity it really is a impactful so
it's a this is our public tour September
19th from 9:00 to 11:00 so we get a lot
of requests but we also do many tours
for for groups for research teams like
if you're interested and like want to
come you know pour with your classes
yeah we would love to host you anyone
recognize this this has a beautiful
nickname the Doomsday vault right like
this is like end of the world
conservation which is an important part
like we want to store up genetic
resources in the event of a natural
disaster or chaos in the world but like
this is our collection so we are
completely vulnerable it's like so we
deal with pests disease like all the
challenges of of an agricultural system
but like we're doing it out in the open
and this you know this vulnerability
also promotes this accessibility so
there are ways that we can keep you know
apples and grapes stored away tucked
nicely and safely in a gene bank in a
cryopreservation system but then when
you want to come and sample the fruit or
evaluate fruit or get pollen for a cross
like it's not available and so this is
like really contrasting other gene banks
that we have seed preservation with all
of our major vegetable crops you know
wheat corn tomato like all of those are
preserved by a seed whereas for apples
grapes tart cherries all of our major
horticultural crops a large majority of
them are conserved clonally so which
means we have to either keep a tree in
the field or budwood in cryopreservation
this is an older picture but like yet
we've expanded quite a bit so back here
is this is
the first part of our Apple collection
here's our grapes and back here on the
hill would be our tart cherry collection
we have about 7600 accessions and this
is one of the largest apple collections
in the world and one of the most you
know significant collections for for
apple you know genetic resources
worldwide we also have one of the
largest grape collections and a small
prunus collection that I'll highlight
each collection individually but this
really is is amazing this technology of
grafting and budding so we use you know
there's lots of techniques to propagate
plans so we use you know clonal
propagation using budding in air so and
thanks to Todd Halloran who's our hand
model here but really so you can start
by you know excising a bud which will go
on to produce a branch which can fruit
which can really carry that genetic
material so these are all corn early
propagated because through meiosis
through sea you know production you've
lost that cultivar identity through high
hetero zygosity so we really the only
way to maintain and trueness the type in
these crops is through clonal
propagation so really exciting a bud
placing it onto a root stock for apple
and cherry woops sorry you know using a
rubber a budding rubber to to hold that
butt in place while it heals you can
pull it off and so here's the root stock
portion and now here's where the bud for
that whatever sign mature you are
interested in will take hold and imp
reduce a new shoes so here's budding
rubber a budding rubber so here's where
the graft has taken hold and then if
you're lucky you'll get a chute so then
from there you can you know you've
propagated a tree so imagine so for each
of our five thousand apple trees like
we've done this that many times to
conserve that those genetic resources
grapes are much easier so grapes hand
sell fruit and actually it for industry
purposes there they are
also are grafted but for our purpose we
want to keep you know just a single
system so that way we can re propagate
from from root chutes as well and so you
know it's a
useful and ancient system to propagate
plants and then here's the
cryopreservation portion so we work with
Fort Collins and their researchers to to
really back up this material on again
this isn't the idea for doomsday we pull
material out of cryopreservation quite
frequently as things are lost to disease
again we are fully vulnerable to
everything and some accessions are
highly susceptible to major diseases but
for Apple and this works beautifully a
lot of stuff can be you know directly
preserved and cryopreservation cherries
a little bit more challenging and grape
is exceptionally challenging so a new
method to preserve grapes involves
droplet vitrification just so now you've
added a step of not only krile but now
you have to go through tissue culture
which as you can imagine is is
challenging as well germ plasm
distribution so this is really showing
our how we touch the world with our
material so a large part of what we do
is make this material accessible to for
breeding purposes for research and so
here this is you know annually of the
national type germ plasm system
distributes about a quarter of a million
woops sorry this is really jumpy about a
quarter of a million exceptions
accessions each year and it's a it's
pretty phenomenal phenomenal when you
see the impact on the world that we have
from Geneva we've you know in the last
five years we've touched 45 countries
and so now they have access to that germ
plasm for their own programs or for
their own industrial development and
that's including a Sita and clonal but
it's really you know quite remarkable to
think about like how we're not only
preserving but sending this material out
into the world so I'll just like to go
by and highlight each of the the
collections on their own so the tertiary
collection so this is not just people
think that art cherry is just a sour
sweet cherry it's actually at different
species it's a hybrid between the sweet
cherry prunus avium and a wild cherry
prunes fruticosa Furtick osa is a
tetraploid so then the hybrid tart
cherry prunus cerasus is this tetraploid
that is is beautiful and diverse and but
challenging to work with as a tetraploid
so they are cold hardy which is part of
the reason that they are in Geneva so
other prunus crops are very cold
sensitive
whereas prunus cerasus is not a large
portion of the collection comes from
Michigan State University and their
their cherry root stock and breeding
program there well I find fascinating
about the tart cherry collection is this
unique chemistry so all cherries look
red but what makes a sweet cherry red
versus a tart cherry is is just a very
different chemical composition and so
this is you know I forgot to highlight
this is Montmorency so this is a 400
year old cherry and I always highlight
this one because most of the US industry
is based on this one
cherry type which is you can imagine
like very dangerous right he's like very
risky so it's about a 70 to 90 million
dollar industry in the US so if anything
happens to this cultivar right like if
the climate shifts and no longer like
can you maximize production or a new
disease or anything that might threaten
its stability you've lost that
production and so when we look at
Montmorency chemistry Montmorency here
when we look at like the anthocyanin
composition it has about 100 micrograms
per gram of tissue but then you compare
it to some of the other accessions which
has nearly you know a hundred times or
10 times the anthocyanin concentration
which also maintains a lot of high fruit
polity and and production value but a
lot of the interest in tart cherries for
tart cherry juice for you know the
nutritional value so if you can increase
the nutritional value by increasing
anthocyanin it's not only do you have a
more stunning product to deliver but now
you know potentially higher a
nutritional content so this this pot
represents that the genetic diversity
within our collection the red is prunus
avium the sweet cherry this is the wild
prune is fruticosa and then here you
have the tart cherries and this
molecular data is so valuable for us
because we find anomalies or mistakes so
if you were to look really closely in
this you would find several part
cherries mixed in with the sweet
cherries
and then when you test their chemical
fingerprint yeah they match that of a
sweet cherry so there's something wrong
in their classification that now we can
address or you'll see several of the
fruticosa actually fall in with the tart
cherries so again so we can find
mistakes we can find relationships and
really understand how to how to better
use our our diversity so this is also a
beautiful project for students to work
on because they can come in in the
summer see the full cycle from bloom to
harvest and they can collect data so
over the last we have five seasons of
data now on the entire cherry collection
really and so the the lines that you see
here in red represent Montmorency so if
that's hard to see we have you know
total soluble solids Montmorency score
is quite low and compared with some of
the other very extreme sweet tart
cherries
you know the same for for malic acid it
scores fairly low on the distribution
for for acidity there's much more acidic
tart cherries weight it actually does
pretty well this is one of the main
reasons why consider the production
stuck-on Montmorency it's a great
producer like very consistent burying
very very good weight is really hard to
beat with some of the other tart cherry
coal tars but this is the anthocyanin
content so this is that unique
anthocyanin and tart cherries and you
see like Montmorency is very low on the
distribution we have some extreme high
anthocyanin content which is really
fascinating from a genetic perspective
and we do hope to follow up on these
studies and understand more the you know
the the accumulation which we show I'm
showing here like several of these
interesting varieties like how they
accumulate anthocyanin content over the
season the showing in by comparison leaf
which remains fairly stable what you do
see like they accumulate anthocyanins
differently I really like to use these
genetic resources we have to understand
like what are their unique qualities and
characteristics so this is a large
portion of our researches you know
looking at the genetic relationships by
characterizing so that no tart cherry
researchers or breeders could come in
and make selections from our material
for their unique projects
now moving on to the grape collection so
this is this is my baby this is what I
was hired to do as the the grape curator
but typically we think of you know Vitis
vinifera the cultivated grape vine and
sometimes we kind of forget the unique
history that grapes have in New York
State and so this is from yupi hedrick's
grapes of New York from 1912 some of
these a beautiful water colors and
really highlight the diversity of grape
so I mentioned the grape collection is
split into two parts in the MGP s the
germplasm system so California holds
most of the grapes which include the
Vitis vinifera your common cultivated
grape vine we have mostly hybrids in our
collection and now I'll kind of a touch
on that a little bit more but really you
can see the the contrast between a
beautiful Vitis vinifera and some of our
grapes that we are working with really
nothing you'd want to see in the store
but they have tremendous value
this was from a project that they our
team worked on several years ago and
looking at you know the kind of the
phylogeny and genetic diversity that
grape vine as a whole and grapes are
kind of unusual in terms of
domestication because they here's where
Vitis vinifera originates from but there
are two centers of diversity that are
not usually those centers or diversity
are also sites of domestication or not
so in in grapevine so really what's
amazing is that we are a center of
diversity for so much grape vine you
know interesting species there's about
30 or anywhere from 30 to 60 species and
hybrids and they get revised quite
frequently but what's so powerful is
that we can use these you know these
interesting and wild species in breeding
especially for New York climates so like
this is you know such a very distinct
climate from from New York State and
where most of the great production in
the u.s. is in California but you know
these wild grape vines can really
span where grapes are grown so this is
just kind of a you know a sliding window
if you want of you know this is wild
species Vitus lebretia
here we have Vitus libretto which is the
the Fox grape which these are very
interesting and difficult to work with
because I think Terry Bates would know
that like you go to grab the berries and
they just all shed so it's like really
different undomesticated traits and
challenging to work with or harvest but
you you hybridize artists Nebraska with
the Vitis vinifera and you get this very
historic and very important hybrid grape
hybrid concord which is one of the most
you know successful North American
grapes in in the world or you can do
another you know hybridization get Keuka
by another very important grape hybrid
this important wine grape
I think contrasted with Vitis vinifera
so like you'll see cluster variation
they you know the berry size the very
color the flavors are all very unique
and when you hybridize grapes you get
the bad with the guts you get the
interesting flavors with the off flavors
or most important importantly for New
York is you get this cold hardiness so
you're like this is uh from Jason Longo
who's our cold hardy physiologist in in
Geneva but like this is something that
Vitis vinifera cannot handle so this is
really limits what can be grown in New
York State or other cold hardy zones
well this is you know probably the
primary reason and threat to our
collection and the reason why we don't
graph is so that as vines die off they
will regrow from the roots and we can
you know preserve the the accessions but
with a with great breeding is you can't
go too far beyond the the cold hardy
hybrids because if you keep it trying to
inter grass get better benefit rates
you're gonna lose that that most
important trait with cold hardiness but
you can also imagine you know disease
resistance by locks for another big pest
all of those interesting traits come
from wild grapevines one of the things
that we've worked on over the last
several years is looking at phenology so
this is very important the timing of
when buds the vines come back you know
leave dormancy when they flower when
they go into fur Aysen so over five
years we scored our entire collection
about 1,500 vines for these diverse
trees
and you can really see like blood break
this first tray like really doesn't
shift too much in comparison with bloom
or for raisin but like this could make
or break your season right if you if you
bloom too or break bud too early in New
York State you're susceptible to winter
damage once you hit that chilling
requirement and I 70 degree day in March
could put your vines in too you know
leaving dormancy and then they're at
risk for cold hardy damage so really
understanding the you know when they
come out when they bloom when they go
into Verizon is important for breeding
and for a conservation perspective so we
want to understand these different
stages so that you know breeders or
researchers could make selections from
our material so really I highlight this
we can break them into categorical data
is using you know just uh you know and
look at them with mosaic plots so here's
blood break in the different stages
early medium and late and then
contrasted with bloom so you see this
very narrow box we had only five
accessions that fit the criteria of late
bud break but also early bloom which
would be fantastic for a climate like
Geneva where you're not you're you're
maintaining dormancy but then you're
also not losing that that growing season
that short window in New York it's
really it's a the two goals or avoid
spring Frost's and developed fruit
before winter which sounds ridiculous
but we have some accessions that will
just start flowering right before the
winter Frost's head in so that would not
be ideal for for New York well this was
one of those five accessions Jiva 1672 a
pre breeding material from a historic
breeder elmer Swenson so this has very
high fruit quality excellent
characterization they described it as
pineapple in flavor and the elicit is
interesting for white wine but here is
one of those you know rare classes where
they they break bud late they bloom
early and then they complete their their
lifecycle before the the winter frost
your us to do a lot with molecular
characterization in grapes we have
several platforms that they've
experimented with SS ARS uh step chips
GBS
Jayda but we can use this to really uh
to understand the diversity and how to
better use our collection so this was a
panel that we had developed for uh for a
study that I'll highlight in a little
bit but we have you know molecular
markers on our grapevines and this one
cluster here is a clone which in the
database it's got a different name it's
listed as one's listed as a wine grape
one it's listed as a table grape so you
would easily mistake it as I you know
these are two distinct accessions but
genetically they are clones of each
other everything that falls within these
two bands are either of our first-degree
relatives either a sibling or a parent
offspring relationship it's really just
by looking at the molecular markers we
can eliminate a lot of the genetic
redundancy that you would want for like
an association study or any kind of more
in-depth characterization now more
recently we're using our champs II
developed from the Vitis gen project and
this will really be able to pull out
pedigree information so now we can look
at hybrids and you know hopefully be
able to piece together their unique
history of when we have the Vitis
vinifera datasets as well so i'm
interested in chemistry and looking at
some of the more natural variation in
our Vitus species and we're starting at
a grapevine evaluation looking at a
Muscat and foxy aromas and there's a lot
of interesting things here we adds grape
or especially from a wine perspective
it's very challenging to say what would
make a good wine from the grape but it's
very easy to say like what are the bad
off flavors but really no one's broadly
characterized our germ plasm collection
so he can at least provide a database
for for individuals to use and like me
well you know select for more advanced
studies that would be fantastic I do
highlight it's not from Cornell's
program but cotton candy everyone always
asks about cotton candy and how they how
they inject it with sweetness and you
know everyone's convinced that they've
done something to give it that
distinctive flavor but no it's it's just
traditional breeding it's just it's that
Vitus libretto a background that gives
it that distinctive flavor and then
breeding for high sweetness and of
course we have Welch's
I lied these are these except accessions
here
I keep losing the cursor these are
hybrids developed out of gala wineries
from our Geneva materials so like to
look at our material and you know you
wouldn't really see much potential very
small fruit very disasterous clusters
but here like within a few cycles you
can actually develop some pretty
beautiful looking cultivars and that
this is really everyone's favorite i
don't sometimes it's frustrating because
everyone when they visit they just want
to talk about apple but it is a
beautiful and exciting collection to
work with and again it's not an all-star
collection like we mix the the great in
with bad and and everything but this is
you know we say an apple a day so with
our collection that's one apple a day
for about fifteen years so students
always ask like have you tasted
everything in my answers no like i can't
possibly taste everything especially if
you wanted to sample it in its prime and
then they get pretty sympathetic after a
week of eating fruit and they they back
off a little bit but it's you know a
wonderful collection to walk through and
taste an apple itself has a very unique
domestication history it apple is a
hybrid so originating a love out of
malice they're out of Cossacks and
Central Asia of malice diversity I you
know traded and then through a clonal
propagation like now you can preserve
genotypes not just trade seeds so these
material you know traveled along the
Silk Route we're a hybridized with
malice Celeste wrists so malice severe
CI is very bland very flat and fruit
quality but it's a nice large size
sometimes the sweetness is there but
then malice of estrus is where you get
that acidity which like combining
acidity and sweetness is like what makes
Apple such an appealing fruit and then
so this domestication you know is a
fascinating process because it's like
masked by evolutionary events masked by
hybridization events and it's very
challenge it's been challenging to
unravel and also Apple is self
incompatible highly heterozygous so it's
only you know it's out breeding only
creates more Jan
diversity for us to use so when you look
at other crops like relatively like
Apple still has not really been fully
domesticated it preserves a lot of the
allylic diversity found in wild
populations and the modern Apple
breeding also brings in other wild
species makes other hybrids to get in a
unique novel traits and I wouldn't be a
good student of Susan Browns if I didn't
highlight snapdragons like we've come a
long ways in terms of Apple history of
Apple domestication it's a-you know
again a fantastic Apple but it's it's
you know she's already looking to the
future breeders are always you know
looking towards that next cultivar like
what's going to be something that
consumers will be excited about
something that will bring new life I
love phenolic this is where I studied in
my PhD and apples are interesting
because not only they don't have the
highest amount of phenolic content and
the foods that we eat but they
contribute about 33% of the dietary
phenolics so if you're thinking
cranberries are like amazing like I
don't eat cranberries every day but
apples are so accessible and I studied a
unique subgroup of phenolic scald
dihydrogen and they are you know there's
only 256 described across the plant
kingdom but in humans like the main one
in Apple floridian has a unique role and
diabetes and this molecular mechanism is
pretty well worked out so that they even
base a pharmaceutical drug on this as
floors in this Apple metabolites
mechanism really we don't understand its
role in plants so there's always like
the idea that oh - alex is related to
disease resistance or there really
doesn't it's not conclusive but they do
find that it might have a role in oxen
so when you silence Florence in
production and Apple you get all sorts
of strange morphology that ensues so
really understanding the more the role
in plants is fascinating getting for me
so I say it's rare and abundant because
it's you know you don't find Florida and
many other plants or another foods that
we eat but it's so abundant in in the
leaves in the bark
especially of Apple and the fruit it
does drop a little bit to 2 to 6 percent
so there's other phenolic that are our
primary in there the
derivatives that are very fascinating so
floridian is the primary metabolite in
Apple but then you get this trilobal
button named after malice kalibata so
then instead of producing floors in this
species only produces try lo button in
high quantities the same with Seibold
and so other species mouse string go
from asia mallas ooh me from Southeast
Asia like these species only produce
Seibold and instead of forwards and and
then you look at the chromatography so
you get these nice profiles that fall
out and it we determined that it really
does follow a single gene code dominant
expression in an apple so we looked at
you know leaf content variation for our
collection so this represents you know
the the diversity of apple species in
our in our collection with Malus
domestica really falling towards the
lower end of the spectrum so there's
some really extreme examples and really
understanding of what is the physiology
of fluids and content like why our
apples producing is so we created some
mapping populations from Susan's program
it's a New York 150 to cross by one of
our wild accessions from our collection
and you see so wow that's it really
jumpy so the hybrid cross was Florence
and type across by one with all three
types and you get this beautiful
Mendelian segregation that falls out
and from there we identified some two
major qtls related to Seibold inand
trial button content but not for florid
s'en it's really we're getting at the
the root of the hydrotech own genetics
in an apple and from there you can get
into more that the physiology and then
like again looking at the genetic
variation so this red group represents
the Malus domestica here's all the
severe cio so this makes sense that you
know these would group closely together
this is the primary progenitor of apple
this is like a hybrid zone and then
these are all the the asian species with
that unique chemical types and here this
is separating it by morphological
characteristics you have all of the
domesticated ones primarily
seperates by fruit size and quality and
then here's like all the wild so the
unique chemistry all resides in these
small fruited you know very bitter very
tannic very acidic apples and then we we
got into sports and these are you know a
beautiful phenomenon in apples or in
clone propagated crops because you can
capture diversity in you know from sport
mutations and so this is all these are
all genetically Golden Delicious these
are arresting mutations and when you
look at the floors in profile in the
peel you see that like this razor this
very rested of mutation has almost four
times the amount of Florida in the peel
as in the the standard Golden Delicious
and this is a beautiful extreme example
of a chimera so this mutation arose
early in these cells and this section is
all rusted so we could sample russet
versus waxy and found it like yeah
Florence and content definitely
accumulates more in the in the waxy or
in the breasted portion than in the waxy
rusting is very common in potatoes and
pears but we don't really see it much in
in apples but this is a very important
historic trait caused by the degradation
of the cuticle in in apples so here's a
nice healthy cuticle and sometime during
early development we see the degradation
and what happens at this stage is the
fruit you know waterproof and lays down
a layer of suberin so we're replacing
cuticle axes with super in there it's
actually pretty rare of a tray in in our
collection so here's zero to five
percent resting and full russets are
actually no not very common when we look
at the Florida and breastfeeding by
group we see that Fords and definitely
increases by loss the cursor there so it
definitely increases by group but also
within group you see a lot of you know
extreme examples in in fluids and
content and sorry for any Honeycrisp
fans like honey chris has very low
fluids and content compared to these are
some of the higher ones with you know
upwards to 753 and Arkansas
lack that's a sorry micrograms per gram
of tissue I'm really the genetic
component explains you know quite a bit
of this is that that skin yes so when we
looked at the flesh we did skin flesh
and leaf tissue there's no difference in
in the leaves you know for related to
resting or in the in the flesh as well
so it is localized in the russet peel so
uh one thing that we can do you know so
we can separate the resting to explain
percentage of floors and content
variation in resting by looking at more
sports so these were a group of five
sport families that like they varied so
the the point diameter size represents
the percentage of floors or the
percentage of rusting and then the
x-axis the floor zinc contents you see
in Golden Delicious you have this
increasing rusting increased floors and
same with the other accessions and now
we're explaining about 62 percent of
Florida and variation with rusting so
it's a really interesting way to to
increase understand floors and
accumulation and development in apples
using this model and again following
fruit development resting begins early
on and this stage this is maybe to two
to three weeks after petal fall an apple
but already rusting is set in here and
you can see it only accumulates for uh
sitting there but the amount of
Floridian that is maintained in these
rested fruits stays much higher and then
in in their waxy type counterparts again
we don't see that trend for for leaves
or for for flesh and really the my
hypothesis is that this pathway of
Floridian and flavonoids is linked into
suberin and lignin pathways as well and
so we have some some studies hopefully
that we can complete looking at the the
gene expression of resting in the
rustling pathway and also makes more
explorations into the floors and pathway
as well and wouldn't you know it so this
was the population I studied it's grown
up now this is Susan's
student but it's segregating for
chemistry and rusting so this is like a
really exciting population to use for
for further studies and dihydrate
chalcones and apples I have to highlight
the exciting cider work and evaluations
that's happening so cider is a very
popular growing trend in apples
heirlooms and and other things but
they're evaluating a lot of the fruit
chemistry food quality associate in our
collection and again this enriches our
collection because now we know more
about our sessions that can be available
to the to the public Thomas Chow who was
the predecessor who the Apple curator
went on this fantastic
exploration to Vietnam to look for wild
Apple and I just highlight that here so
before this exploration only a single
accession of this this tropical timber
apple malleus do Mary here's the fruit
here so they went into the jungles of
Vietnam to collect materials seeds and
brought those back so those will be
housed in Geneva and in Corvallis Oregon
because they are very cold sensitive
really just highlights you know the
group that we work with the fantastic
USDA team but also several people that
we collaborate with Cornell University
and and thank you and I'll take any
questions that can come up yes yeah not
so much so tissue culture will give you
a lot more epic genetics the soma clonal
variation we do try to capture when we
find interesting mutants we do try to
capture and propagate those they don't
always take so really those mutations
are still tremendously valuable but
still rare so I mean it was still the
genetic the composition is there the
allelic variation is there even if the
trait has slightly shifted so do we need
like what is like dozens of sports of
Red Delicious to conserve Red Delicious
so you may not know like Red Delicious
the original was not as red as
today and they've selected redder and
redder skort mutations
it's like whether we keep one at the end
or the actual tree alive so that's yeah
that's it's a concern but Prime it's
more keeping up with diseases our
primary okay so if Alex or we we just
deal with we just tolerate because it's
our vines are have resistance so we get
foliar Phil Ochs row which is
unappealing to look at but it really
doesn't impact the vine vigor
whereas finish yes and it is a major
concern a great story of like a gift
from North America to Europe was our
gift of powdery mildew and flocks right
but we swooped in with our germ plasm
and saved the day so now they primarily
use root socks developed from North
American species that have that Fox
resistance rates there's several private
meters that might get material from you
so what do they get and what do you tell
them about phytosanitary status of these
things yeah so the phytosanitary is
challenging because we can't promise
that the materials disease-free we do
say it's pest free we so mostly viruses
is the biggest concern for grapes yeah
it's looked at that's generous its yeah
we have some virus problems but really
there's the only way to remediate that
is to do you know do cryotherapy or
thermotherapy
to get clean lines which we cannot
feasibly do so yeah we put out the the
notice that we you can't expect
everything to be disease-free though
although we do have inspectors come and
look for for pests so we do our
diligence to not you know spread disease
especially a international you know we
don't really export anything grape
internationally so they do have some
pretty strict requirements in the EU and
and elsewhere we do yes yeah so a lot of
you know grape industry will get pollen
from us that they can use for crosses or
seeds or easily exchange although those
through carry
viruses as well well it's the challenge
because we don't want to there's no
point in keeping the material for not
distributing it so if we can't get it to
the people who need it and who were we
what are we serving here other than it's
nice to have a historic collection to
walk through so it's like keeping up
with distribution
unexplored or the drip laps and still
there we'd love to go to bring out so
there there has been some more work like
I'm just thinking of like Italy right
now so I have to Malus accessions or
seed accessions that are unique species
to Italy and that like have never really
been explored so I'd like I'm
germinating a subset of those for now
but you Heather there's material all
over the world Thomas Chao really was
exploring native North American malleus
species looking at you know so he was
hoping eventually I think exchanged more
into Canada but exploring the southern
region in the eastern regions a lot has
been done on the Pacific crab from
California down to Oregon and BC and all
of that well yeah there's still there
still places not just for our crops all
over the world so M PGs sponsors you
know plant exchanges or exploration
visits to these sites I think there's
another trip to Vietnam in the works so
they didn't get enough there they want
to go to different sites and greet more
back so it's a continual process of
exploring for plants bringing them into
the collections
so we brought seeds back from Vietnam as
well as some science so the signs go
directly to Beltsville I believe I might
be over you know thinking that one but
like so if we go out and find unique
trees in the forests of like Kazakhstan
where the original curator Phil fors and
when he brought those back some of those
are still in quarantine trying to be
cleaned so there's I think one accession
since the 90s but they just can't get
virus clean to clear to release to us so
yeah so with seeds they can go through a
quick evaluation and go directly to the
site so we already have
access to the do marry seeds now it's
just if there are any interesting Conal
berry you know types that were from
Vietnam that they want here so the so we
have a vast collection of mouth severe
CI from Kazakhstan and most of that came
through a seed it's a lot of late nights
of the hotel collecting fruit and then
pulling out seeds very exciting yes we
know that there are many North American
how they came here presumably was
understanding of it's a it's a great
question and I'll you know add my own
philosophy is it like with our
horticultural crops a lot of those
questions get ignored so we want to
really understand domesticated crops but
then we forget like oh there's this
strange group in North America like when
you do the genetic studies they are most
basically related to the other Asian
apple species so presumably they might
be more ancient is the thought than some
of the the Central Asian apples which is
really interesting because how do they
get here so we have three species on the
East Coast and then the southern regions
and then one species on the Pacific side
that one is more closely related to the
Asian apples so there's that idea that
came through on the land bridge but like
how these North American apples how they
fit into the evolutionary history but a
lot of again it's unfortunate that some
of those studies get ignored or kind of
overlooked it because they the priority
is that you know to serve the industry
and and yeah yeah a lot of them are
beautiful from an ornamental perspective
like the Prairie crab malice Iowans is
like a lot of like multi petals a lot of
beautiful colors the fruit is not
anything too exciting but maybe from a
cider perspective there's some unique
chemistry there yeah from yeah from a
botanical like we all care about the
botany not just the the horticulture but
really is unfortunate that we get kind
of pigeon-holed towards the domesticated
crops
so I'm that slide about the rust rusted
sport population yes it was five or six
different cultivars that are in the
future you wear all those support all
those rusted sports also represented in
Geneva were you collecting yeah this is
100% Geneva yeah
so there's definitely other russets for
families or others interesting sport
families that we could I think from a
conservation perspective they're not
very useful because you're not you're
you're kind of is a lot of allelic
redundancy but then you have that one
unique characteristic that you want to
propagate but from a research
perspective like keeping clones even if
they take up space like it's very useful
it's like conduct research on
anthocyanin content or accumulation or
this was perfect for our study in
Russert II so then you kind of have to
like go back and forth I'm like do we
need more support families or like do we
pull back and only preserve the high
diversity material because I noticed all
those names were ones that had been
collected by the eggplant but I didn't
realize that there were all these
Russian sports of them also yeah
question so are you saying that they've
might be another so generally what we
understand is that the apples moved from
Kazakhstan this way and also gets at
land so it's there is there's another
way that the apples came here maybe so
this is showing the I'm sorry if you do
need to leave no worries
so really this showing like the
domestication history of the modern the
Western Apple right so like there was
actually another route that Apple's took
the other side of the mountain into
China it's like their server see I
they're like they're cultivated Apple is
unique genetically from the Western
apples that have been developed but in
terms of like so along this
they passed like maybe six seven other
apple species like they didn't really
contribute to domestication so like how
they got there like going past and
through Italy there's massive Escher's
but there's also Mouse Florentina
there's also Alice piccata which is like
understanding how that one contributed
as well it's really again like we don't
know much about the evolutionary history
of Apple so a lot of work was done in
the 90s with Emily Dixon Cornell PhD so
she did a lot of explorations which
Thomas tried to follow up with and
seeing are these sites so there are
these native populations and now we have
the material can we do genetic studies
and see more their unique history this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu